finally I want to thank
God because God gave me this
dundy and I feel God in this Chili's
tonight the busiest Beaver award goes to
Phyllis
leapin yeah way to go Phyllis nice work
per usual this says bushiest Beaver what
I told them busiest idiots it's fine but
we can fix it we'll fix it up you don't
have to display that so when we get to
the Rison i' like to I changed it to
Chili's excuse me Rison just gives out
this Vibe it's like oh I'm doing
business at the rattis and it's kind of
snoody so you had no right to do that
Michael here's the thing Chili's is the
new golf course it's where business
happens small businessman
magazine it said that it will I sent it
in letter to the
editor this next award goes somebody
really lights up the office somebody who
I think a lot of us cannot keep from
checking out the hottest in the office
award goes
to Ryan the
[Music]
[Applause]
T you
sexy you here you
go hanging in a
from baby there you go there you go what
am I going to do with the
award nothing I I don't know what I'm
going to
do that's the least of my concerns right
now hello Christian yes I thought that
was you hi hi Michael Scott this is Jan
levenson Gould just Jen levenson no G no
thank you very much for meeting with us
have you been waiting long no not long
good uh J what happened Michael is cool
dead what uh Michael we got divorced
okay I'm so sorry EXC W you're kidding
me do you want to talk about it Michael
could we have a table for three please
when did this happen we're in a meeting
okay this way please all right after you
thank
you I bet we could start by going over
the needs of the county right Well laana
County has not been immune to the slow
economic growth over the past 5 years so
for us the name of the game is budget
reduction Awesome Blossom what I think
we should share an awesome Blossom what
do you say they are awesome you want to
Christian awesome sure okay it's done
actually Megan may we have an awesome
Blossom please extra awesome now it is
done so um I Heard a very very funny
joke the other day you want to hear
Christian you don't you don't have to
listen to this we it's okay I like jokes
okay just the one just one joke okay
well if it's just going to be one I will
think of a different joke
um Dunder Mifflin this is Pam Pam it's
Michael I need you to go into my office
and check some data for me okay um you
want me to read them yes okay um a
fisherman is walking down Fifth Avenue
leading an animal behind him nope told
it not as good as you think pick another
one okay there's a transcript between a
naval ship oh okay Bingo and a
lighthouse yes that is hysterical could
you start that one from the beginning
sure there's a transcript between a
naval ship and a lighthouse what a great
year for the dundies we got to see ping
and we learn Michael's true feelings for
Ryan which was touching and we heard
Michael chain the lyrics to a number of
classic songs
which for me has ruined them for
Life what
nothing
okay what I don't know
what oh my God you are so drunk did you
get that please tell me that you got
this is all going to be on woman is grab
grab T it's okay I'm a sheriff's deputy
well he's a volunteer don't get into
that now we need something to cushion
our head throw pillow
I'm
oneir I'm sorry sir you're going to have
to put your clothes people are trying to
eat wait please look
look in addition to Severance and
everything I want
to give
you this gift certificate to Chili's for
me okay no heart
failings
Kevin Jim Pam Kelly Toby Oscar Meredith
Phyllis Stanley or the temp if any of
you want to meet me for a drink I'm
going to be a Poor Richards the rest of
you can go to
hell that's delicious I love it we would
probably be upset with ourselves if we
went this whole night without talking
business so Dunder Mifflin can provide a
level of personal service to the county
that the Warehouse chains just can't
match well we are out to save money
what's the bottom
line that's why I wanted a signal
between us so I wouldn't have to just
shout nonsense words that's her fault
did somebody say baby back
ribs I don't think Christian has time
for that I have
time I want my baby back baby back baby
back I want my baby baby baby I want my
babyy I'm going to get a drink do you
need anything oh I'm fine thanks
sweetheart Billy your nurse is hot it's
my
girlfriend your nurse became your
girlfriend sweet she was never my nurse
I met her at Chili's she was my
waitress chili is
great
and so after watching my mom go through
so much pain I decided to keep that
promise that I made to her and take care
of
her well this brings us to Jan Truth or
Dare tell us about your divorce oh no
Michael Michael Michael Michael please
no oh really hey so you're not going to
play she's not playing she's not playing
the game we've been fighting for a while
he didn't want kids I knew that going
into it but he also knew that I did so I
guess I thought that he would change his
mind he thought that I would change mine
you didn't I was stupid no no you were
not stupid Gould was stupid right that's
right you know you're really Brave I
mean you you put your arms out there you
slit your wrist it's true you said world
this is my blood it's red just like
yours so love me oh my God I just want
to say that this was the best best
dundies
ever whoa whoa careful careful careful
we have a strict policy here not to over
Sur apparently this young woman was
sneaking drinks off other people's
tables iser Rock her driver's license
and she is not welcome at this
restaurant chain ever
again